نحن على مشارفي
وثقافه العيل بيجي برزقه لا تزال شائعه
بين مواطن الفئات البسيطه في مصر
ومحركا اساسيا في ارتفاع معدلات الانجاب
واستمرار زياده السكانيه لكن كيف جاء
مفهوم العيل بيجي برزقه المشكله مركبه
وتجره معها الكثير من المشكلات واساسها
التسرب من التعليم
اول يوم الامور في كثير من المناطق يجبرون
ابنائهم على ترك المدرسه
لمساعدتهم على جني لقمه العيش واستغلالهم
لجلب عوائد ماديه في ظل غلاء المعيشه
الحكومه المصريه تخطط لفرد عقوبه صارمه
على اولياء الامور بالاسرى التي تتعمد
تسريب اولادها من التعليم
ومواجهه العماله تحت السن والاهم تقليل
معادلات الاميه حسب ما اعلن رضا حجازي
وزير تربيه والتعليم في كلمته الاخيره
امام البرلمان
[موسيقى]
الجهل هو راس الفتن ومصائبه لا تاتي فرادى
التصدي له بحسم يعني القضاء بالتابعيه على
ظواهر تؤرق المجتمع وتعرقل اي خطط للتنميه
لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره